one of the stars of Hellboy which is in
theaters this Friday he'll be in John
wick along with Keanu Reeves and Halle
Berry and Laurence Fishburne and crew
coming up next month
in May when also the return of dead wood
with Deadwood the movie that is none
other than Ian McShane here on the
program good to see you nice to be here
what a pleasure to have you
your dad was a football or is that a
Manchester United came down when he was
like 15 from Glasgow and played the
Blackburn Rovers when in the war came
out played briefly for Bolton Blackland
then united sign new 1950 we moved to
Manchester and then so I grew up knowing
every all the players are still close to
everybody because when he finished he he
carried on as a scout for the club and
as I sort of Iran the he did the
announcements at halftime put the
records on were there in those days and
like any he's you know he will kind of
because you know they're yet a PA system
you know play a few records you know
buncha ster United reggae whatever and
it was I mean they still played now
because I was back there about when was
I back there about six weeks ago I saw a
game it's about to say how often do you
go and I try and go well my mum still
alive she lives about ten minutes from
the ground still so I see her all the
time I go back and visit her and then
I'm lucky enough to catch a game there's
Alex Ferguson's one of my oldest friends
so ok but I gotta say mm-hmm you know I
mean all these great time but up you
know this year I'm Manchester City and
they do play some beautiful football you
got to give it up and you know but I
don't want them to win the quadruple no
we won the trouble we can't have them
win in the quarters
give us a break would you Pepe you
should have come to us anywhere in the
first place who is your favorite player
just period that you've you remember
either growing up watching or even job
so film and seeing players I mean I go
back to you know de Stefano could
probably be compared to anybody any
player the great Argentinian sort of
wandering Real Madrid when Real Madrid
will help started that you know the
galaxy goes if you like in the 50s when
they collected a lot of the hunger I
think the Hungarian side which is
revolutionised soccer for me when I sell
with my dad and watch them beat England
at Wembley
6-3 and 1953 push
Sidda Gucci bought vehicles named gross
each they're a phenomenon the side then
they had the revolution and the Real
Madrid plucked if you like like push
ghosts and that started de Stefano from
argent and then they played and I saw
them play United Real Madrid you imagine
in the 50s in England this drab night
and all these guys ran out in all white
with tans anybody went on shoes you know
well and they played as good as they
look so I've always had a sneaking sort
of liking for Real Madrid in a way even
though it's you know it's a completely
mostly about organization my most are
most our sport cuz there's so much money
but we both know that but they keep up
this you know it's fascinating I love
the European Cup we go Barcelona next
this week which is tough right it's
tough the European competition is tough
well I mean there's a Champions League
game against Barcelona coming up in just
a comment yeah I mean no I went to the
last final with Barcelona which is a
kind of a cruel lesson we look great for
10 minutes never saw the ball again you
know for the entire game you're gonna be
you know I'm on my momma thon but I grow
up with the game so I know about sports
and that level of it which is it's a
cruel thing
Ian McShane here on the Rich Eisen show
we'll get to Hellboy John wick Deadwood
and the rest of your filmography in a
second any American sports teams that
you're partial to at all yeah I really
have a always a sneaking love for the
Raiders when I first came over and
suddenly found the first team I sell
play the Oakland Raiders then they came
here I wish to go and see a couple of
games here but the atmosphere was very
dodgy in Louisville in the 80s it all
got confused with sort of you know
identities in game became a sort of
going down it was interesting we fight
the games for their boots you know it's
all there's ik family then one that can
you ever been to the black hole up in
Oakland you ever go to Oakland no but I
mean I saw them there but that but
watching that team I mean Stabler was
like a wonderful player to watch if you
wanted to know about how does well
football right
you know I mean Kenny Kenny the snake
right yes let Nicole from those gray
roots Leicester hazel stick him at the
back and then yeah doctor amazing
defense you know and he was like a
mixture of all those players
nobody wanted also run by guy was the
most interesting guy in that in NFL I
was about to say because he didn't seem
to fit amongst all these you know super
corporate people and he was a coach Dale
Davis was one of those people but she
reinvented the game if you like and the
way was level played also you know rich
you could explain that dirty word
socialism to America view money by
saying that's what the NFL is based on
if you want to look at the politic it's
very successful because you put in you
take out and that's what it is but it's
like I'm not on the higher level but
it's like it's a it's a great game but
he's gone dissipated over the years I
don't know so much you know when they
changed the rules it's used it to make
it protect the quarterback because now
you know the athletes is so expensive
take other people don't like
thoroughbred horses you know taken away
whatever that's why I think the calls
have become so weedy
in basketball games like that was judged
to love my my favorite basketball team
was the Pistons the 88 I love that the
bad when he walked up that I was great
when she orden in that love and they
were anyway screw you and they walk what
a two minutes to play they walked up I
thought I was yes that's my kind of
thing they saw no it's like everybody
thought you know when Robert dear I'm
Roberto Duran for sugar right sugar
right for the last ten seconds of each
round rather than that but I never liked
Jerome was like he wasn't like no more
he went not cut no more I can't start
gonna crank me no I love this by the way
just to be talking to guy who played Al
Swearengen with talk al davis with him
this is fantastic and you love the bad
boys to ian mcshane here on the Rich
Eisen show alright let's talk about
Hellboy it's the third live-action
Hellboy film we just saw a clip of it
and it is just nothing to do with the
other two rights the other two you know
actual lovely metaphysical versions of
Guillermo is great imagination strikes
Mike Mignola who wrote the comic but
wanted to go back to our hardcore yeah
in your face violent characters and
knowing where they are and this is a
complete reboot in every way and as
Johnny heard you played my part when our
oldest pals in the acting business
touched on before we did this I sort of
was like this really yeah
you know and then working with David
who's really embody for graces the Royce
guy he's terrific on on the other actor
Sasha and Mila and Daniel no it's good
it's it's it's a really great popcorn
get out there I max it looks great this
Bay it's very violent very profane
mm-hmm watching American football I
think I don't know what Hellboy would be
a hell of a pass rusher I think an edge
rusher just go he'll take somebody out I
think he could play any position what do
you want to play me however you want to
play right exactly
did you enjoy doing Oh live action
yeah no I mean it was good I was in
Bulgaria for a month I mean it's these
great studios which used to be the old
communist studios this producer avi
Lerner bought them turn them into this
very successful studios which produces
all those expendable movies and all the
other stuff and they're very experienced
over there it was guy I was there for
three weeks three months might have been
different richer is Sofia Bulgaria but
three weeks was really great right and
the finest vegetables I've ever tasted
is that right yeah because it's close to
Greece it's an interesting place but all
those places that have been sort of
infected by Soviet ISM not coming in
Soviet ISM nothing they take years to
get over all of the the intrigue and the
Emperor you know and all of the baggage
that came with that kind of a
totalitarian regime you know it's cruel
on people I think they're getting over
it but Romania places like that Hungary
I mean we film that because it's it's
cheaper you know tax wise they get
Britain almost break right but the
people are hugely talented and they're
certainly it showed up on the screen
I'll tell you that I mean you play again
you play the adoptive father professor
Trevor Bruton home and and you mentioned
David Harper just a great L boy and yeah
the series I'm truly loving the reboot
John wick three comes out in the middle
of May as well yeah you're back in that
you're back in that great no one
wondering again what happened you know I
gave him a now so now the high tables on
my ass nor on Kiana's house
on fishbones ass you know that
everybody's ass and rifle trade by this
terrific actor Kate Asia Dillon who
plays the representative of the high
table sort of strange body of people who
don't know and it continues again it's
this adventurous and it ends with the
enigmatic oh really
worship because you notice gonna be a
full well come on now I mean you can't
explain it all in three you have that
right for whatever but he could it was
good it was sitting nobody sure and I
love Keanu kyani's top man he's a great
guy no well because he's caring
portrayal of him is the John wick
portrays you know John wick he's like
the guy he's like the open hand karate
is like he does everything right and
he's methodical and he's because he's
like here he is again oh Christ he's
coming it's not that sort of you know
flashy whatever it's like a but it's
less what I do
money terrific the word he's a and he's
a class act gay in his own life so so
you're in a sequel with John wick and
then uh American God season two's out
now and it looks like you got another
series three and again the so probably
late summer them ya know it's in grace
that's been a big hit in places all over
the world from the Greg novel because I
always thought it was a perfect
blueprint for TV series to do the book
and then you can take off on these wild
side adventures of talking about all the
big things in life as long as you come
back to the main book which is the old
gods one I may come back again you know
display your faith to go around give me
a little I'm here McShane here on the
Rich Eisen show all right I love to talk
to Edward with you if you don't mind
no do that it's just like your character
Al Swearengen whenever there was a
luminary that would come into his saloon
you would open up the can of peaches so
I have with you here right here on the
Rich Eisen show I got a can of peaches I
died ate the mold so let's open up a can
of peaches and talk about right there if
you don't mind would you like some
people think it no I'm fine double cream
came a thing he seemed lime and eek
that's the genius of milk she wrote the
show it became like I'm sure it was one
of those things that they talked what
would they celebrate they said well
there's a meeting of the challenge
one of the gun they're all drinking what
are you gonna eat you can't bring out
where I can't go now and say bring a
basket from you know Gelson's what we
got cans of peaches and of course there
everybody got diarrhea from them that
first day of you remember but learning
that that's milk she's genius about the
guy who wrote the show created yes and
the nice thing about the show I think
rich the fact we were able to come back
and do the two hour movie was it they
waited until they could get us all back
I mean they could have done maybe a
one-off over with Tim Oh Tim and me and
alright I always say you know Alan Seth
ride the high country you know but that
wouldn't but not the same it's not
wouldn't that this looks right into your
but you know it's like every because
that's what made Edward Deadwood wasn't
a show about just these two guys
although they are important different
sides of a coin whatever cuz you know
Bullock's is crazy as Swearengen when he
goes when he goes out one on one and
that was Tim's great thing he thought
he's you know he said he said I'm
playing I said yeah yeah the straight
guide this one because he was used to
playing offbeat kind of you know right
but Tim was just terrific he's the moral
core of the story along with you know
all of terrific people in it and that
was great that we all came back it was
thirteen years later we're all thirteen
years old and we see someone's had seen
each other now and again or kept income
but it was the same respect the same
respect for the characters the story of
the show cuz it was a fine show fine
sure remarkable I mean I it was
remarkable to work on him in every
respect I haven't got one like cynical
or even negative word to say even though
he came off there after three years I
mean that's got nothing to do with you
you can't that's got something to do
with write whatever this is this film
pick up right after ya know there's a
link it picks up ten years later its
statehood day ended Lingus take yeah
it's become a state South Dakota so
there's a legitimate reason for Gerald
McRaney to come back again because you
have a senator but he's got business
interests and we hopped back to what
happened ten years ago because trick is
gonna be tricks this big day I won't
give that away and some of
way and of course you hog back to the
last episode when we took it with him
when I when I hatched this when we all
hatched this plot and to kill the
prostitute in place of encapsulation
Trixie and of course this comes apparent
in this it's a good it's a very clever I
think cut back to that a memory a memory
of collective guilt on their part so you
never get away from that in Deadwood
because terrible things have been done
but at the same time there's a moral
sense of the challenge groan ten years
later bullet Alma comes back because
she's got to take care of her property
she owned the bank I mean there's a
legitimate beef on everybody everybody's
back last gift about milk because he
does gave everybody the great you gave
everybody their watch as we say yeah
yeah I mean to me some of your
soliloquies as Al Swearengen as that
character yeah would be would go on for
minutes at a time how did you approach a
scene like that how how did you learn
the lines in that regard and and and be
able to get through a scene like some of
these that you were in you never even
questioned it I mean I think in didn't
nobody did I mean we all had them at
various points Billy Sanderson had them
as EB Farnum he'd have these shakes you
know suddenly and some of the most foul
I am became fantastic to do I mean but
you know any actor that I said doing
that show was like being on you know
David would come up say I've just
watched the first thing because he's
what you rehearse and then you go funny
come back and say like weak this and
then sometimes you say I'm sorry I'm
gonna come back at lunchtime give you
know few more lines and people go oh
it's okay mm-hmm because you trusted
each other you were in a place where you
overused phrase now a safe place but you
were yeah everybody was there the
writers the directors the editors the
COS you know there was no question that
you could do so it was like being in you
on a self-contained studio
self-contained group of people and one
guy who was smarter than anybody else in
the room who was really leading the show
so you felt yeah now so you'd be part of
the acting everybody brought their
a-game and just got on with it
all right before I let you go I want to
play a game that we call here a
celebrity true or false in which I ask
you a couple questions from previous
interviews that you've done or to see if
it's true or false from the in it or
anything like we research on the
Internet let's do that but celebrity
true or false again a Hellboy in
theaters near you this Friday true or
false you have an obscene amount of
socks and underwear is that true or
false
very well okay moving you going out you
never know you could be hit by a bus so
make sure you work you don't know is
that the way it works in my mind I mean
when you pack you pack an extra well now
you know so much because you can get him
anywhere you get them online but I mean
no I mean but this goes good to have
that yes okay next one because I'm
getting old and our problems otherwise I
just gotten by a big pack of depends
okay one of your favorite foods is
clotted cream
rice pudding from Marks and Spencers oh
that was it I remember that was quicker
oh absolutely that was a question of
well what would you fear most and I said
Marks and Spencers running out of
clotted cream and porridge or four more
years of that owners gentleman okay very
good I think I know you're referring to
I didn't know which first which would
scare me more last one powers Boothe who
was the light powers Boothe unfortunate
would not be in this nude Deadwood film
he was originally cast as your character
Al Swearengen but fell ill before the
pilot was filmed and that's how he later
appeared in the series is sight
Tolliver's at a true story I think it's
true yeah apparently yeah he was you
know otherwise why would they have gone
to England good an actress they probably
thought I was to find an American no
runs a bar in Deadwood in 1886
but you know sometimes parts have got
your name on it so whatever whatever
happened however it found its way to me
in the end and the rest is whatever
we're very welcome to have powers in the
second seasons in place i but sadly you
had a recurrence of whatever it was and
do it I know do you do you have was
there someone in mind that you channeled
to portray I don't know I know the first
they said you I was just I was in
England they said you wanted America
Cirie's I said no one no not
particularly it's not you know I just
been my own show in England called
Lovejoy which was done right I'm
produced a couple of other independent
things with the BBC and then they said
well it's HBO and it's multi hills
directing it and David I said when do i
where do I go right because you know you
think in the why and it was like and I
it just happened literally like that I
went into video and a chat with him next
I mean I was on a plane and then I did
her sometimes you haven't I couldn't
wait to sort of it's one of those babies
bit of a genius and Walter you know
directed the pilot beautifully and it's
one of those things one of those things
I can't wait to see everything that
you're in from Hellboy this Friday to
obviously John wick coming back for John
wick three Americans God's American Gods
is honored stars on Sunday nights and
then a season three of that and then the
Deadwood film on stuff to keep up with
you man but I appreciate that you came
in to do well thank you nice to talk you
you bet the man who is one of my
favorite characters in all of television
man played Al Swearengen ian mcshane
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on Direct TV for free on be
our live or download the Rich Eisen show
app